當你看到現沖的獲利金額
實際上獲利金額會比這個來的小
大部分都這樣啦
大部分
大部分各位你看到現沖的獲利或虧損金額
實際上的
應該說一般人啦
除非你鎖漲停
鎖漲停不一樣
鎖漲停是
他現沖的獲利都很醜
因為他有時候是
那個賣3%嘛
然後漲停再買回來
那這一段還是算現沖
賣3%漲停買回來算現沖
那他以實現水運會非常漂亮
但是我們不是說漲停的
所以我們有時候我們的現沖的獲利
會比實際上獲利金的還來的少
因為有時候虧損然後等到明天再補掉
那我的習慣就是怎樣
這個不曉得衝一衝虧損的
我隔天早上我都會處理
所以有可能前一天是
中培
然後隔天就變小培
前一天中培隔天變小培
就像我昨天我有空一檔股票叫新能高
但昨天新能高沒有跌下來
我今天要PO新能高
昨天空新能高
昨天新能高沒有跌下來
那今天早上他就開低
那開低很多人都會做一件事
他一定很多人都会去
他会去看他的成本多少
到我的本没有
各位你要记得这句话
你千万别去看
再跟各位讲一次
到本的没有
再讲一次
你千万不要去看到本的没有
你要
先怎么样
你要先把它买回来因為你每次假如去看道有沒有你很有可能就是你很有可能就是
沒有到那價格你就不會買
沒到那價格就不會買
那沒到那價格你不會買
因為還沒到你成本啊
那你不會買
你不會買呢
你可能今天又錯失一個
做單的好時機啦
來來來
所以跟各位講
這個盜不到本真的不重要
到不到你的成本不重要
重點是你的錢要趕快回來
這裡啊你看
他一開盤一殺地我就趕快買回來
趕緊買
拉高賣盤捷徑
買盤捷徑啊
買盤捷徑我就再賣一點
殺下來我再買
這是我的手上
已經沒有新人高了
我已經把昨天新人高
大概
中培的部分
變成小培
因为昨天那个还没有大赔
只是赔
应该赔几万块
反正这个杀下来
做个当冲
大概赔个剩一两万了
反正就赔很少
赔很少
然后呢
这时候我已经没有部位了
后面再拉上来
震荡
到了尾盘
尾盘我会想一件事
我早上买那么多
我在这边卖掉多漂亮
多漂亮
我这个当冲多美
我這站當中就很漂亮了嘛 對不對
你看我在這裡買 買42餒 賣45餒
對不對 我想把它賣掉是不是當初很漂亮
明天 BBU 壓力應該蠻大的
我是這麼覺得啦
因為今天 今天的老大叫做新勝利
今天的老大叫做新勝利
所以新勝利都沒有所長頂的
我覺得明天他會有壓力
那年代的会影响到这些BBU的概念股所以呢我還是先賣掉還是持有的空單再持有空單一次
比較沒差就是
我今天就變成純當沖了
我原本是回補找小培的
我現在變成當沖
變得很漂亮
因為這樣子做
其實你的成本
你的那個會變得很漂亮
你的損益啦
損益会变美
就是当你这样子有处理过
就是你开盘
反正昨天空哪里
我不记得啦
所以每次
每次有人来问我问题
小哥我这张股票
我新人高啊
昨天空在41块
请问明天能不能解套
看起来像
我看起來像那個嗎
像廟宫嗎 還是我看起來像什麼
我看起來像算命的嗎
我哪知道你能不能解套啊
我不知道你能不能解套啊
好不好 我哪知道啊
我知道 我不是神就是神棍
我又不是神 我也不是神棍啊
對不對
我騙你 我唬隆你 那我就是神棍了
對
我也不是神
所以我怎麼知道你的解套
你記得你痛苦啊
你懂我意思嗎
你記得你痛苦
我不記得我開心啊
我開心啊
反正我就補掉就好啦
因為這些都不重要
跟各位講
這些都不重要
重要的是你趕快把你的錢拿回來
因為我們做當充的
我們會留一筆周轉金幹嘛
會留一筆周轉金
在做什麼事呢
我們再回來看這張圖
再回來看這張圖
章圖的意思就是說
你做當中你可以做得很漂亮你只要按照我的方法教你的教你的你做 你會做得很漂亮你的以實現損益很美啦
再跟我講
你的以實現損益很美
很美 然後呢 沒關係
你未實現醜一點沒關係
你早就把它處理掉就好啦
早就把它處理掉
這個原本賠個五萬的
有機會變2萬出場
那你不用去記
到底是幾萬到幾萬那都不重要
重要的是你趕緊把錢拿回來
你懂我意思嗎
你趕緊把錢拿回來
就是
你今天講要回補了錢就回來了嘛對不對
那你看我這樣子做
我這樣做之後
我只把錢拿回來
我這伙頭到底是哪個戶頭
這個不只把錢拿回來
我整個還
還變得更漂亮
整個還變得更漂亮
所以我覺得這一招齁
這一招我覺得
真的真的很重要
最後在這裡齁
我有開一個交易補習班
那後面的時間還沒巧啦
因為快過年了很多時間都
很多還沒巧
那我們有在台北的有第一堂
第一堂是這個限量實體場
台北的有第一堂課是在1月19號
1月19號
地點呢在這個這邊
好
這時間
這時間他打錯了
我再跟他講一下
沒那麼長啊
要3個半小時
太長了
我們還是兩個半小時的還是兩半小時
好就這樣子
所以那個再跟各位講一下